同学们
今天课堂的议题分享内容是一个人资源越匮乏
人生越完整
听起来是不是很有趣
想要迫不及待的分享呢等等
我们依照惯例先来朗诵一首韵脚诗
今天要分享的是横着走的青春
用铅笔仔细描绘出纸上的我们
框框里好多等待填空的人生
却又怕说好的未来失了真
于是盖上书本
但总还是溢出的几行横着走的青春
同学们有没有注意到我们的歌词创作班
很特别很有趣
因为我们分享了很多歌词以外的领域
譬如说我们除了学习歌词心思
也欣赏了书法
建筑跟当代艺术
甚至我们探讨了
或者说我们批评的星座
也分享了阅读的意义
之所以做这么多元的课程安排
而这个能力有助于形塑自己的创作态度和风格
好我们进入今天课堂的主轴
就是一个人资源越匮乏
人生越完整
怎么理解这个问题呢
因为你资源越匮乏的人
你就会主动性地去争取
你身边没有任何可以提供给你的一些辅助
你就会自己想尽办法绞尽脑汁
这样子的一种学习和吸收是主动式的
而不是被动地等别人给予
譬如说如果人生像一本小说
那资源越匮乏的人
恭喜你
你这本人生小说非常的完整
怎么说呢
因为呢你人生小说的每一个章节
每一个篇幅
每个字句都是自己写
或者说几乎都是自己写
怎么理解
当一个环境优渥的人
他的所有生活上的功绩
他在学校的安排
甚至于人际关系
基本上或者说大部分可能来自于家长的关系
来自于家族的安排
他可能是企业二代
也因此呢他可能从小时候学校学区的筛选
就读的学校
一直到相处的朋友圈
甚至于毕业之后的企业职位的安排
都是父子辈家族安排
好好的
等于是你人生是一本小说
你人生小说里面的章节
题目标题是别人帮你写好了
读什么学校
交什么朋友
进什么公司
做什么工作
人生如果像一幅地图
你这幅地图的路线非常的清楚
但非常的清楚
没有坏事
就是路径很明显
你就照着走
很顺利
直走就到终点目的地了
但是人生就真的只能这样子吗
是哪里觉得不对了
如果说你人生很匮乏
家境没有很优渥
不能提供你更多其他的选项或者是资源
不能去补习啊
不能学才艺啊
不能做任何的一种本质学人的嘉奖
这个时候人的本能反应就会出现的
你就会自己去争取继续吸收
而且自己选择就说你可能自己选择就读的学校
就读的科系在哪里交朋友
什么样的朋友圈
甚至于未来的工作
因为家庭没办法攻击你
一旦家庭家族没办法攻击你的时候
你就会自己
去争取你自己争取的时候是你自己的主张
都是你自己的决定
也因此人生这本小说相对而言
你自己执笔的程度就非常的高
很完整
比如像我
我本身也就是所谓的蓝领阶级
就是父母的工作类别一个称呼
但是呢因为他们没有办法给我课外的补习
从小也没有上过才艺班
我甚至没有读过幼稚园
因为我们在花莲台湾这个东台湾乡下
一个叫富里的乡下
那个地方的幼儿园很少
我们家四个小朋友都没有读过所有的幼儿园
但是我觉得没有关系啊
那段时间我自己去到处跟邻居玩
然后跟兄弟姐妹玩
然后自己去吸收
那到青春期的时候呢
连朋友圈父母都不干涉
因为他们忙于工作
忙于三餐的温饱
他们没有多的闲暇时间去照顾你
所以我几乎所有的小说都是我自己写
跟朋友圈
那我几乎我的人生的这本小说
从头到尾连标题都是我自己写
这样的人生很畅快淋漓
为什么
因为你资源很匮乏
所以我说资源越匮乏的人
你的人生越完整
听起来是不是很特别的一个观点
但是呢不是说家庭优渥
含着金汤匙出生就是个原罪
不是的
那是你父子辈辛苦努力得来的
为了给你更好的学习环境
所以你要更努力才对好
所以同学们理解这个题目的意义了吧
一个人资源越匮乏
人生越完整
真的是这样子
用不同的角度
有自己的思考方式去解决你面对的所有问题
而且还有一种就是说比对法
怎么个比对法呢
很多时候幸福感是比对出来的
你觉得你好像缺少了什么东西
总觉得应该拥有一些更多的资源或家境更好
然后你可以买车
你可以住比较好的房子啊
或者职业类别的选项
甚至于学历
但是请记得幸福感是比对出来的
怎么讲呢
你手头上拥有的东西你不会去珍惜
为什么你本来就拥有了
一般人都不知道感恩现在的生活状况
通常你的朋友圈
每个人一个频率会跟你成为朋友的人
通常你们的思想想法见解视野各方面有个频率
你才会常常地相处在一起
也因此这样的朋友圈朋友有的你也有朋友
没有的你也不会拥有
我打个比方好了
就是说很多地区的民族
他们的生活可能不如我们现在的生活状况
但是因为你不是那个地方的人
那你的生活离你太遥远
你不能想象举个极端的例子好了
可能像非洲
非洲有一些物质条件相对差的部落
那部落不是你生活圈
不是你的同学
不是你的朋友
不是你的邻居
你只会跟你的邻居
跟你的朋友比
你不会跟居住在那边的人比
因为他不在你的生活范围内
那边的人可能缺水缺电
可能连周末去看电影
都都觉得是无法理解的事情
为什么周末要去看电影
周末要去打猎吧
他去取水吧
一个礼拜里面可能只有某些时刻有电力
那更遑论有网
网际网络可以使用
还有电影院可以欣赏看那个电影的
最近有什么院线片要上了
有什么主打的墙片要上了
那个是他们无法理解的事物
再举一个古代的例子好了
你今天如果生活在明代好了
在明代
因为社会条件的限制
社会不那么多元
假设可能经济地带有个人对昆虫很有兴趣
画画了很多昆虫的图鉴
研究昆虫的生态
然后呢没有用啊
八股取士不考啊
科举制度不会考你昆虫的生态啊
那怎么样的软化
然后涉猎的食物是什么东西呀
然后它生命周期有多少
那时候的考试不考啊
所以你懂那个领域的知识没有用嘛
可是现在生活很多元啊
你重视只会给绘画
你重视只会城市设计都没有关系
因为现在社会的分工很仔细
任何人都可以找到自己的位置
在职业的职场上
所以呢这些你没办法感受
因为你没办法比对
再举个例子
像印度有种姓制度
它有婆罗门
刹帝利吠舍
首陀罗是个种姓阶级
一出生你就是首陀罗
首陀罗就是农民
但是根深蒂固的阶级制度已经深植人心了
各个种姓阶级是不互相通婚的
那你不是很冤枉吗
你从事的可能是尸体的屠宰
甚至于说排泄物的处理
因为种姓阶级烙印在你身上的身份
你只能做这些事情
那这样子一种身份的不自由
你没办法感受到
因为你不是印度种姓阶级制度里面生活的人
那样子的比对吧
你比对不出来
你只会跟同学比
他有手机
我也有那所有手机
你不觉得幸福
因为我有的他也有啊
人是贪心的
别人可能周末可以去看场电影
你也可以看啊
你觉得看场电影有什么了不起吗
这是什么了不起的幸福吗
所以你就不觉得看场电影
这种寻常的快乐是幸福
多数人对幸福的定义一定是定义在
你没办法拥有或没办法达到的目标
达到了拥有了
你觉得才是幸福
所以有手机你不觉得幸福
然后有水电充足的房子住
你不觉得幸福
周末可以去逛保险公司
可以吃东西
吃美食
然后看一场电影
你也不觉得幸福
人家可以安排去旅游
大江南北的跑
你绝对不会觉得这是幸福
为什么别人也可以呀
别人也可以做
也可以拥有的事情
你就不觉得是幸福
但是呢你想想看
譬如说可能古代一个宰相好
他住在长安京畿地带
一人之下
万人之上
然后又怎么样
他能旅游吗
不可能吧
他可是像现在啊
你如果在住在东北
然后一张高铁票
一天之内你就可以到江南了
你就可以到浙江到江苏这个朝代限制的想象
古代人可以想象吗
事情还安排粮草什么的
筹划了多久
然后行程也很慢
你说受力车能多快
马匹能多快
不可能吧
你现在不是宰相诶
你也不是帝王
也不是贵族哦
你没有这些身份
这些古代所谓尊贵的身份
也就是一般的所谓的平民好了
这是一个学生
一张高铁票
一天之内就到江南了
这个是没有办法想象的
这是时代的限制
我们现在的人光出生就很幸福了
为什么
因为我们生活在一个最美好的时代
没有战乱
个人生涯的规划就不会被剥夺
你有一个大型的战争
大时代的动乱象个人的选择权是很卑微很小的
甚至没有
你还想要学习哪个艺术领域
然后对金融
对城市设计
对影像
对摄影
对灯光有兴趣去学习
没门不可能
只要动乱大时代战争
个人的生存就是第一要务
活下来
90%的愿望就是活下来
然后另外10%个人认识的人都在就好了
还有什么生涯规划
生活品质的追求
不可能嘛
你一出生就有网络系统了
你就可以打线上游戏了
然后呢你就可以自由的假日的时候去逛街
然后去旅游
这些你视同理所当然的事情
很多的朝代
很多的种族是没有办法拥有的
而一旦你拥有之后
多数人都觉得说那就是生活的常态
不是吗
那这个有什么值得一提的呢
记住我说的幸福感是比对出来的
每个人的人生只有一条轨道
如果你的人生诞生在不同的经纬度
你现在所能享受的东西是差距
是非常非常的大的
大道觉得说天哪
原来可以自由地选择
想要过什么样的生活是一种幸福
没错
最大的幸福就是你想要成为什么样的人
的这种选择权
你有选择权的自由
怎么理解
你可能对金融有兴趣
对影像有兴趣
在这个时空背景
你只要对哪一个领域有兴趣
你就可以主动去吸收
去学习
成为你想要成为那样的人
就是成为你羡慕的对象
他不在你够不够努力而已
你们扎扎实实的从基础去建立
去学习
去吸收
朝你想要前进的目标迈进
想要成为什么样的人呢
这种选择权是很珍贵的
这是很幸福的
就像你们报名的歌词创作班
你选择了来听这堂课
你有选择权
你有学习的选择权
你有职业类别的选择权
你有兴趣的选择权
而这个选择权
如果你时空的经纬度横跨到1000年
500年200年
你就会发现现在有多幸福了
你可以想要成为什么样的人呢
这种选择权
就像你今天因为选择了歌词创作班
而听到的这堂课
你在选择你有自由的选择
因为自由是很可贵的
举例来讲
当你作奸犯科
你犯上了刑事案件了
然后你锒铛入狱了
你失去了自由
可是有没有想过一个问题
其实你还活着
衣食无虑
三餐有攻击
然后可以睡觉诶
他不会虐待你
说不能睡觉
因为现在比较文明的
你就算入狱了
你的作息是正常的
你也可以睡
也可以吃
也穿得暖
也吃得饱
但是大家都很害怕
纵使只是被判了半年入间
没有人受得了
因为你失去了对生活节奏的选择权
礼拜六想要睡一整天
礼拜天想要逛街
那礼拜一好好的工作或上课
你没得选择
今天生病了
赖个床
我今天心情很好
早点出门
你没得选择
所以呢选择权是很重要
是不是很珍贵
这种幸福感是比对出来的
当一个人失去自由了
一听哇
这次的刑事官司他可能犯了抢劫或团伙犯罪
可能判了10年
天哪你失去了10年对生活的选择
那是多大的打击
多数的状况下没有人愿意
因为呢我想要吃个泡面
我想要吃个夜宵
我想要熬夜追剧
最近流行什么电视剧啊
没得选啊
你你可以追剧到天亮吗
因为你现在可以追剧到天亮
你不觉追剧到天亮什么了不起呀
可是有一天你锒铛入狱了
你就作息都很正常
很规律
你可以在自己的牢房里面追剧吗
追一个偶像剧什么的嘛
然后一次看四集
我就看到天亮吗
不可能奢望无名
世界对人最大的制裁就是剥夺他的时间自由
我没有取他的性命